C'est
nous n'avons qu'il y aura un point pour le
détecter et automatiser les tendances
mois où tu n'as pas à faire attention
Donc avec 50, je ne sais pas, y a du boulot, ouais
surprenant je pense cette année
Il y en a, mais j'ai toujours pensé qu'ils étaient là
à côté de là Diana
Que ma journée soit si grande, les gens
si
séparé et je ne peux pas mourir parce que
ça vient de colorer le bonbon, c'est tout
parce qu'elle devrait rester, les gens l'auront
de GNR la clé d'un bon Casino était que
Il ne demande pas, il y a un feuilleton, c'est pas tous les jours
qui est pour l'avenir de Cláudio Filosofia
Il n’y a même pas de papillons sur la plage, tu sais ?
[Musique]
la course sur le terrain Ne te perds pas, je peux juste
vas-y ton frère mais comme ça T3
option qu'on déteste fort et le canard
parce que Paty doit supporter le froid que je
Je dois faire briller une lumière à l'intérieur
de ce groupe et est presque dans votre corps et
Aussi les adultes, qu'en est-il du vôtre ?
sauver mané est
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
resterait
avec elle et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
décoller décoller décoller
Ligue de justice de Jennifer Jennifer
Jennifer Jennifer sera-ce
Ce qui sera
Que sera Regarde, regarde, regarde, regarde
ET là
[Musique]